こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
皆様
回転寿司
好きですか
好きですか大好きで
背景を見ればわかりますなかなか食べたい
ものが回ってこない時とか自分が食べ
たかったものを
前のお客さんに取られたことありますか卵
食べたいなってこれ貰ってくるやつは待っ
てた時に
前の席に座ってた人たちがそのそれを取っ
て食べちゃうとかあると思うんですけども
それを今回意図的に起こしたいと思います
全てというわけで今回の企画は回転寿司
食べようと思ったら
前の席にデブが4人来て全部食われたら
どう
ドッキリ
今回ですねスシローさんスシローさんの東
静岡店に来ております
ご協力ありがとうございますじゃあ早速
最強のおデブさんお呼びしましたどうぞ
よろしくお願いします
というわけで今回は元お相撲さんにお
集まりいただきましたよろしくお願いし
ます
合計体重を知りたいんですけど皆さん体重
って何キロぐらいですか120kg
120km
僕も120kg120kg140140
キロ130km130キロ合計が
約500キロぐらいで
結構食べられる感じですね
ありがとうございますお腹の方は空いて
ますかね
今日はもう死ぬほど食べちゃってください
というわけで皆さんにお願いしたいのは僕
と
ターゲットが一緒にお寿司食べてるんです
けどもその前の席に来てもらって
改善してくるお寿司を全部食べてください
僕たちのところに一つも来ないのを続けて
いただけると
助かりますどう行動するのかてかそもそも
気づくのかどうか結構
可能性もありますやっぱすごい仕掛けて
いきましょう
もしもしろ肉
[音楽]
スシロー来れますスシローテレビに渡す用
の
撮影なんで
密着の
お願いしますというわけで今から
ターゲット来るんですけども
怪しまれないように
先に大地君と俺はたくさん大歳を頼んで
おきますで俺たちは食べてるけど
後から来たターゲットはレーンにも来ない
タッチして頼んだやつも食べられるという
ことで一生来ないという状態を作り出し
ます
[音楽]
いろんな
場面に出すんで
みんなバラバラで予定が昼飯のどんって
やつですねお願いしますというわけでお
昼ご飯でございます
[拍手]
俺たちに先に着いたからちょっとたくさん
食べてるんですけどこっから傭兵君が
200皿
[拍手]
[音楽]
めちゃくちゃ行くやないですかもうまずは
手始めに
ダメダメだねいやー
[拍手]
言ったっすよね今まもなく注文の商品届き
ます
からねよくありますからねなんか
さすがに
卵ちょっと
結構いっていいですか
[音楽]
よそろそろ
[拍手]
見えてるよ
[音楽]
デザートの中だ
なおちょっとようやく
今日初甘エビも来た今日の恥ずかしい
[音楽]
ご注文いただきました
多分俺と
俺の甘エビを卵にありますよ
[音楽]
聞いてみますいややばいでしょこれ
ワンパンですよね
ないから
多分食べられてますよ
それそれもう一回
頼むで大丈夫ですか
気づきました
実は俺たちの例に1回もお寿司来てないん
ですよね
全部この方達が
食べてくれました車にその
もしもしあお疲れ長沼のスシロー来て
欲しいんだよね
わかりましたOkです入り口前着いたのは
教えて
はいよしたくさん食べような
気をつけてはいお願いしますというわけで
早速お寿司を頼んでいこうと思いますはい
スシローの特徴としては
タッチパネルでできるんですよ
お相撲さんにはそれすらも食べてもらい
ます
皆さんは絶対真似しないようにお願いし
ターゲットが来て
もその出てくる
[音楽]
というわけで何もないと逆に俺たちも
食べれなくなるから今のうちに頼んどき
ます俺たちはい
え誰
え誰これ
[音楽]
早く
来ました
[拍手]
よく来るよな来ますね18
ぐらいが来るんですよね
間違いないですね
[音楽]
走ってきましたから
これ待ってる時間でね
ワクワクなんすよ
間違いない
だけですエビバジルもいっちゃうよ
ちょっといいですか
メロンソーダですよアクセスといったら
超お腹すかってきて
朝ごはん抜いてきたマジはい
本気じゃんいや本気っすよ
[音楽]
[笑い]
待ち遠しいですね
いやそれうまいでしょまじうまい
[音楽]
[拍手]
大変そうねぇ
いいんですか
[音楽]
結構頼んだのまだ来るよ
意外と
警告からですねあ
流れてくるんだけど
[音楽]
エビも俺だ
これじゃないっすよね
流れてくれても分かってる
誰か取られたかさすがにさすがにね
早く食べたいやつ食べるかなんかまだ人と
卵食べないと欲しいじゃないですか
[音楽]
全然来ないぞ
全然来ない
まあでも一番最後に来そうっすね
なんか後ろのすごい人いますね
離陸したのけど
来たぞ来たぞ
赤のサラダ
[音楽]
うわ食べとるわ
全部
前の席のお相撲さんに食べられるドッキリ
でした
美味しかったですか